we're told use the interactive graph
below to sketch a graph of y is equal to
negative 2 times 3 to the x
plus 5. and so this is clearly an
exponential function right over here
let's think about the behavior as x as
when x is very negative or when x is
very positive when x is very negative 3
to a very negative number like you said
let's say you had 3 to the negative 3rd
power that would be 1 27 or 3 to the
negative
4th power that'd be 1 181st so this is
going to get smaller and smaller and
smaller it's going to approach 0 as x
becomes more negative and since this is
approaching 0
this whole thing right over here is
going to approach 0. and so this whole
expression is if this first part's
approaching 0 then this whole expression
is going to approach 5. so we're going
to have a horizontal asymptote that
we're going to approach as we go to the
left as we go as we as x gets more and
more negative we're going to approach
positive 5
and then as x gets larger and larger and
larger 3 to the x is growing
exponentially but then we're multiplying
it times negative 2 so it's going to
become more and more and more negative
and then we add a 5.
and so
what we have here
well this doesn't this looks like a line
we want to graph an exponential
so let's go pick the exponential in
terms of x
there you have it and so we can move
three things we can move this point it
doesn't even just have to be the
y-intercept although that's a convenient
thing to figure out we can move this
point here and we can move the asymptote
and maybe the asymptotes the first
interesting thing we said as x becomes
more and more and more and more negative
y is going to approach 5. so let me put
this up here
so that's our asymptote it doesn't look
like it quite yet but when we when we
try out some values for x and the
corresponding y's and we move these
points accordingly hopefully our
exponential is going to look right so
let's think about let's pick some
convenient x's so let's think about when
x is equal to zero if x is equal to zero
three to the zero power is one negative
two times one is negative two plus 3 is
3. so when x is equal to 0
y is 3. and let's think about when x is
equal to 1
what and i'm just picking that because
it's easy to compute 3 to the first
power is 3
times negative 2 is
negative 6
plus 5 is negative 1. so when x is 1
y is negative 1.
and so let's see does this is this
consistent with what we just described
when x is very negative we should be
approaching we should be approaching
positive five and that looks like the
case as we move to the left we're
getting closer and closer and closer to
five in fact it looks like they overlap
but it's really we're just getting
closer and closer and closer because
this term
this term right over here is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller as x
becomes more and more and more negative
but then as x becomes more and more
positive this term becomes really
negative because we're multiplying it
times a negative two and we see that it
becomes really negative so i feel pretty
good about what we've just graphed we've
graphed the horizontal asymptote it
makes sense and we've picked two points
that sit on this on the graph of this
exponential so i can check my answer and
we got it right